[Aplausos]
[Música]
2020 ha quedado secuestrado por la
pandemia del sars coronavirus 2
[Música]
sin embargo más allá de esta crisis hay
acontecimientos que merece la pena
contar que tenemos que contar y uno de
ellos es precisamente este durante estos
primeros meses del 2020 eeuu ha puesto
fin ni más ni menos que a la guerra más
larga de toda su historia amigos creo
que casi todos podemos recordar cuándo y
cómo empezó la guerra de afganistán
crimen
[Música]
en berlín
lo que seguro pocos esperaban era un
final así 19 años después se ha llegado
a un triste epílogo para dos operaciones
militares que recibieron nombres tan
grandilocuentes como libertad duradera y
centinela de la libertad
[Música]
a todo un despliegue de medios
sufrimiento y dinero para que al final
la libertad en el país afgano haya
tenido poco o nada de duradera y que
bueno lo de ser centinela no haya
quedado más que como una especie de
broma en el marco de la nueva estrategia
del américa first
[Aplausos]
así que la pregunta es que supone
realmente este acuerdo entre la
administración trump y los talibanes qué
papel jugará este asunto en las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu y lo
que es más importante para afganistán
cuánto va a durar la paz
invito al político y vamos a dar
respuesta a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
una derrota silenciosa
afganistán celebró en 2019 el centenario
de su independencia respecto al reino
unido- 100 años de independencia como
país aunque lo cierto es que en este
caso lo de celebrar bueno digamos que
sólo es una forma de hablar
los afganos llevan más de 40 años en
guerra pasando de un conflicto a otro y
luego a otro y a otro algo que
evidentemente tiene consecuencias
afganistán es hoy el país más pobre de
asia es un nivel de desarrollo ha
retrocedido a niveles de 1950 los
problemas modernos de afganistán
comenzaron en 1979 cuando la unión
soviética invadió el país para apoyar al
régimen comunista surgido de la
revolución de saúl eran los tiempos de
la guerra fría y la reacción de eeuu no
se hizo esperar
jimmy carter- primero y ronald reagan
después apoyaron a los muyaidines en su
lucha contra los soviéticos el país
nunca más experimentaría una paz estable
y duradera
el caso es que según parece en ese
momento en la cia vieron a unos
muchachos barbudos disparando
alegremente sus rifles al aire a alguien
en langley y le debió parecer buena idea
financiar a aquellos rebeldes islámicos
el resto de la historia es conocida los
soviéticos se retiraron derrotados y
eeuu evitó un régimen comunista pero la
paz no llegó a afganistán
las luchas internas continuaron entre
los señores de la guerra y finalmente
afganistán acabó en manos de los
talibanes
un grupo islamista que se hizo cargo de
gran parte del país en los años 90 y que
sorpresa sorpresa todavía están por allí
mirada de esta noticia de hace un año
el ejército estadounidense deja de
contar cuántos de afganistán está
controlado por los talibanes y cómo
podríamos resumir el régimen talibán en
pocas palabras
[Música]
pues quedamos con que instauraron la ley
islámica y que tuvieron muchas
muchísimas ideas eso sí todas o ribles
por ejemplo desterraron a las mujeres de
la vida pública y las encerraron en sus
burkas y en sus casas dinamitaron los
budas de bamiyán símbolos del patrimonio
afgano que acogieron a terroristas
islámicos como osama bin laden
no había pasado un mes del ataque del
11-s cuando george bush ordenó el inicio
de la operación libertad duradera en
en los distritos mencionados para volver
a ver al indigente en la mujer sing
comenzaron entonces los bombardeos sobre
los talibanes y las fuerzas de al qaeda
y poco después la invasión del país como
podéis imaginar 19 años de guerra en
afganistán dan para mucho y en todos
estos años 2011 supuso un antes y un
después
[Música]
pero cuando el 2 de mayo de 2011 eeuu
acaba con osama bin laden es como si de
repente si hubiera cerrado la etapa
iniciada al 11-s a partir de ese día
permanecer en afganistán resultaba cada
vez más incómodo y la justificación cada
vez más difícil de entender por eso la
administración obama trazó un plan de
salida la otan y eeuu redujeron las
tropas sobre el terreno y en 2015
comenzó la operación centinela de la
libertad
el objetivo dejó de ser combatir a los
talibanes para limitarse a formar a las
fuerzas leales al gobierno y que fueran
los propios afganos quienes se
encargarán de garantizar la seguridad
del país
[Música]
y qué pasó entonces pues ya lo vimos
aquí en visual político en un pasado
vídeo a medida que la otan retiraba sus
fuerzas los talibanes recuperaban
terreno
[Música]
sin embargo desde entonces la sensación
generalizada en occidente es que lo peor
de la guerra ya había pasado algo así
como vale no me iré de vacaciones a
kabul pero bueno las cosas ya no están
por afganistán como estaban en 2010
cuando la otan sufrió más de 700 bajas
y si es verdad en los cinco años que ha
durado la operación centinela de la
libertad tan sólo cayeron 110 soldados
de la coalición
pero queridos amigos queridas amigas de
fiscal político esto esto no significa
que la tranquilidad ha vuelto a suelo
afgano en afganistán fue el año pasado
peor que en siria un dato para que os
hagáis una idea más de 25 mil 25.000
personas perdieron la vida en afganistán
tan solo en 2018 el año con más muertos
desde que esta guerra empezará en el
hoy los talibanes están activos en el
70% del país y dominan casi por completo
las áreas rurales
así que sí ya casi no mueren
estadounidenses pero en cierto modo las
cosas en afganistán están peor que nunca
19 años de presencia occidental en
afganistán no han servido ni para vencer
a los talibanes ni para crear unas
instituciones democráticas fuertes que
se hagan con las riendas del país el
gobierno afgano no tiene ninguna fuerza
frente a las jerarquías tribales la
situación es tan complicada que en
septiembre se celebraron elecciones y
los resultados no se conocieron hasta
febrero cinco meses más tarde para colmo
tanto el presidente afgano como el
opositor abdulá abdulá se han atribuido
a la victoria a falta de un gobierno
fuerte actualmente afganistán tiene dos
gobiernos igual de inoperantes
pero digamos la verdad todo esto no le
importa a nadie absolutamente nadie las
negociaciones sobre el futuro de
afganistán las han realizado eeuu y los
talibanes sin tener en cuenta al
gobierno de kabul
pero puede que llegados hasta aquí
estáis preguntando os pero qué opina
donald trump de afganistán
pero walter bayly en vivo
en este intervalo want to win the world
alliance tim white world the face of the
arts el picante de abril pudieron
entender el área rural
el caso es que antes de ser presidente
trans siempre dijo que sacaría a las
tropas de afganistán que los americanos
no pintaban nada por aquellas tierras
sin embargo como ya os contamos aquí en
visual político cuando llegó a la casa
blanca de continuidad a la estrategia de
barack obama con un cambio fundamental
evitó marcarse una fecha de salida
y la verdad es que esto fue todo un
acierto porque puedes haber pensando un
momento que ocurre cuando los padres le
dicen a sus hijos adolescentes que no
van a estar en casa a un fin de semana
pues que montan en casa
la fiesta del siglo y cuanto más tiempo
les des para organizarla más amiguetes
vendrán a la fiesta pero donald trump
que tiene cinco hijos dijo aquí no me
vais a pillar en afganistán actuaremos
según las circunstancias y es que este
escenario el juego con los talibanes no
es muy diferente y no tener establecida
una fecha de salida es una de las
mejores cartas que se pueden tener para
negociar
de hecho eso de fijar de antemano fechas
de salida fue uno de los grandes errores
que cometió barack obama
el caso es que los talibanes que ya se
habían puesto a jugar al force night
mientras esperaban que occidente hiciera
las maletas se dieron cuenta de que
contra tenían que cambiar de plan que
por mucho que sus tropas avanzarán en el
terreno esta guerra contra eeuu no la
ganarían nunca en el campo de batalla
[Música]
ahora bien teniendo todos estos
comodines en la mano porque no ir a una
mesa de negociación
pues dicho y hecho esto fue exactamente
lo que pasó atentos
[Música]
talibanes en camp davis
cuando donald trump invitó en septiembre
de 2019 a los talibanes a la residencia
presidencial de camp david para firmar
un acuerdo de paz finalmente dar un
golpe en la mesa todo un golpe de
imágenes
y claro la imagen de los talibanes en
camp davis en eeuu el mismo lugar donde
egipto israel pusieron fin a 30 años de
conflicto sonaba muy interesante a un
año vista de las elecciones trans sería
para siempre
el presidente que acabó con la
interminable guerra de afganistán
sin embargo por desgracia para el pueblo
afgano los términos en los que se mueve
el acuerdo entre eeuu y los talibanes
nos llevan a pensar que toda esta
significación tiene más que ver con
necesidades de guión que con que los
malvados talibanes se hayan vuelto
buenos de repente
prueba de ello es lo complicado que han
sido las negociaciones fijaos
donald trump del ego en el diplomático
afgano americano zalmay khalilzad las
negociaciones de paz que se
desarrollaron en doha entre eeuu y los
talibanes que no estuvo presente en la
capital catarí fue el gobierno afgano
que ha sido un cero a la izquierda
durante todo el proceso y es que acá
lista ya tenía un acuerdo cerrado desde
el pasado mes de septiembre
de esta forma todo quedaba dispuesto
hasta tal punto que trump invitó a los
talibanes
and the beat para rubricar para firmar
el acuerdo en vísperas del aniversario
del 11-s esto en la cabeza de trump
sonaba fantástico
pues espera un momento porque pocos días
antes fue cuando se produjo este gran
declara que las conversaciones entre
estados unidos y los talibanes están
muertas después de cancelar la reunión
de camps davy porque canceló trump el
encuentro con los talibanes cuando todo
estaba listo había algo del acuerdo que
no le convencían pues
lo cierto es que no lo que pasa es que
hubo un atentado talibán en kabul y
murieron 12 personas vamos lo que viene
a ser un día normal en la capital afgana
pero justo esta vez murió un soldado
estadounidense en la casa blanca a
alguien se le ocurrió decirte verdad
vamos a firmar la paz con unos tíos que
son incapaces de mantener una tregua
mientras negociamos así que el acuerdo
estuvo a punto de saltar por los aires
por supuesto que un político como trump
de por muertas las conversaciones en
septiembre quiere decir en realidad que
dos meses después ya estaban negociando
de nuevo
y ha cambiado para entonces nada
absolutamente nada solo que trump tiene
entre ceja y ceja que llegará a las
elecciones de noviembre siendo el
presidente que cerró el conflicto afgano
donde ha muerto más de dos mil soldados
estadounidenses más de 20.000 han
resultado heridos se han gastado un
billón de dólares más o menos en el pib
de españa en un año
[Música]
y seamos claros lo que menos le importa
a donald trump es el futuro de
afganistán
el acuerdo de paz recoge que eeuu
retirará todas sus fuerzas de afganistán
en 14 meses a cambio los talibanes se
comprometen a no acoger a organizaciones
terroristas internacionales como al
qaeda vuelta es así mismo se emplaza a
los talibanes a negociar el futuro
político de afganistán con el gobierno
afgano conversaciones que deben
acompañarse de intercambios de
prisioneros y rehenes por ambos bandos
[Música]
sí ya sé lo que estás pensando parece
más las condiciones de una victoria
talibán una victoria estadounidense
pero amigos a estas alturas eso ya no es
lo más importante la clave de todo esto
es si de verdad se puede confiar en los
talibanes y la propia administración
trump lo tiene claro no mucho
ahora bien queréis saber qué vídeo eeuu
a los talibanes para demostrar su buena
voluntad atentos
[Música]
el amigo del mula
después del 11-s y tras 19 años de
guerra el gobierno norteamericano pidió
a los talibanes que demostrarán que
podrían estarse quietecito durante una
semana
sí como si esto fuera una especie de
terroristas anónimos hola soy talibán y
llevo cinco días sin poner una bomba
ánimo chaval
estamos contigo
el caso es que según el gobierno afgano
durante esos días la violencia se redujo
un 80% lo suficiente para eeuu que esta
vez si firmó el acuerdo con los
talibanes
[Música]
claro que eso fue el 29 de febrero
sabéis qué pasó tres días después pues
esto los talibanes reanuda los ataques
contra las fuerzas afganas mueren cinco
policías efectivamente los talibanes han
firmado el acuerdo con eeuu pero siguen
atacando a las fuerzas afganas tampoco
es que sea una sorpresa porque es lo que
han estado haciendo todo el tiempo que
han durado las negociaciones de paz
[Música]
que dice pues sobre este asunto el
presidente está 100% en modo electoral
soltando siempre que puede frases tan
emotivas como ha llegado la hora de
traer a nuestra gente a casa
[Música]
mientras los talibanes atacaban a los
afganos el presidente eeuu decía cosas
como esta
igual si este vals pero el socio
vamos que estamos a punto de presenciar
un acuerdo de paz que no significa otra
cosa que una retirada sin importar las
consecuencias claro que en el caso de
afganistán tampoco está claro que hay
alternativa
pero la cuestión es servir a este
acuerdo con los talibanes para la
propaganda de trump
es seguramente si los demócratas
intentaron con obama ganar la guerra
poniendo 100.000 hombres sobre el
terreno y fracasaron en consecuencia by
the no puede presumir mucho sobre
afganistán además asegura que siempre
fue partidario de reducir las tropas
allí
[Aplausos]
también es cierto que abandonan
afganistán a su suerte no parece que
importe mucho a los estadounidenses a
edad el coronavirus
[Música]
pero estas alturas seguro que os
estaréis preguntando pero a ver a
alberto y el gobierno afgano que dice de
todo esto al fin y al cabo los talibanes
siguen con su misma hoja de ruta ataques
a las fuerzas de seguridad afganas
coches bombas atentados es más las cosas
se han puesto en un plan que si a un
talibán le queda una bala en el
kalashnikov pues disparan test a un
policía afgano que a un soldado
norteamericano total los yanquis están
retirada pues fijaos las negociaciones
entre el gobierno afgano y los talibanes
tenían que haber empezado el 10 de marzo
no sólo sin embargo todo va con retraso
el presidente ashraf ghaní y el oponente
abdulá abdulá aún se están disputando el
poder además los ataques talibanes se
suceden y por si todo esto fuera poco
hay un obstáculo más que ralentizará la
marcha del proceso el coronavirus
también ha llegado a afganistán
bueno al menos las últimas noticias
indican avances en el intercambio de
prisioneros y rehenes como punto de
partida para empezar a negociar
afganistán se prepara para intercambiar
siempre y son los talibanes por 20
miembros de las fuerzas de seguridad el
gobierno afgano tiene dos bazas para
negociar y la verdad es que no son
precisamente buenas
una es el apoyo de las tropas
estadounidenses que dentro de un año ya
no deberían estar allí y según lo
pactado por donald trump la otra es que
los talibanes quieren la libertad para
los miles de sus hombres que han metido
en versiones afganas la otan eeuu y las
fuerzas gubernamentales y claro según el
acuerdo firmado por trump el gobierno
debe liberar cinco mil talibanes antes
de que empiecen las negociaciones
políticas por el futuro ya cual están
las importantes de verdad
así que más o menos ya podéis haceros
una idea de quién lleva las de ganar
pero ahora es turno para ti estás de
acuerdo con la fórmula elegida por
donald trump para cerrar la guerra de
afganistán déjame tu respuesta en los
comentarios y si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante darle al botón de
like un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]